$200,000 IN FINES BUT ALL OF
THAT COULD BE DRAMATICALLY
REDUCED IF THERE'S POTENTIAL
COOPERATION THREAT.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
STUDENTS, PARENTS, TEACHERS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE ASKING
SOME HARD QUESTIONS TONIGHT
ABOUT LAST WEEK'S SHOOTING IN
SOUTH FLORIDA.
THOSE QUESTIONS COME AS WE LEARN
MORE ABOUT WHAT THE FLORIDA
HOUSE SPEAKER CALLS "AN ABJECT
BREAKDOWN AT ALL LEVELS."
CORRESPONDENT PHIL KEATING HAS
THE LATEST TONIGHT FROM
PARKLAND, FLORIDA.
>> MY LAPTOP WAS STILL THERE.
YOU KNOW, UNGRADED PAPERS THAT
WERE STILL THERE.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE 150
BULLETS WERE FLYING DURING THE
VALENTINE'S DAY ATTACK, TEACHERS
WERE ALLOWED TO RETURN TO
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH TO
RETRIEVE PERSONAL ITEMS
ABANDONED IN THE PANIC.
>> THERE WAS HUGGING.
THERE WAS HUGGING AND SOME
TEARS.
HANDSHAKES AND GLAD YOU'RE BACK.
GLAD YOU'RE BACK.
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAD ENOUGH HUGS TO LAST ME,
YOU KNOW, A LIFETIME TODAY.
>> THIS AS DISBELIEF AND
DISAPPOINTMENT RAGED NATIONWIDE
AFTER THE REVELATION THAT AS THE
SHOOTING WAS HAPPENING, THE HIGH
SCHOOL'S RESOURCE OFFICER RAN TO
THE FRESHMAN BUILDING ARMED WITH
A GUN BUT NEVER BARGED INSIDE.
THAT OFFICER, SCOTT PETERSON, A
30-YEAR VETERAN WHO WAS AWARDED
BEST SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER
FOUR YEARS AGO FOR HIS TACT AND
GOOD JUDGMENT, ACCORDING TO
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF, HE HAD
NEITHER WHEN IT MATTERED THE
MOST.
>> WENT IN.
ADDRESSED THE KILLER.
KILLED THE KILLER.
>> ANOTHER MISSTEP AT THE SCENE,
OFFICERS WHO THOUGHT THEY WERE
WATCHING A LIVE FEED OF THE
SHOOTER INSTEAD WERE WATCHING
DELAYED SECURITY FOOTAGE.
THE SHERIFF ALSO HAS SUSPENDED
TWO OF HIS DEPUTIES WHO
RESPONDED TO SOME OF THE 20 PLUS
CALLS FOR SERVICE TO DEAL WITH A
VOLATILE NIKOLAS CRUZ IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
ONE OF THE INSTANCES INVOLVES A
CLAIM THAT HE PLANNED TO SHOOT
UP A SCHOOL.
AND JUST MONTHS AGO --
>> 911 EMERGENCY?
>> ONE OF THE DISPATCHED CALLS
MADE BY THE CONFESSED MASS
KILLER HIMSELF.
THIS TIME SUGGESTING HE WAS A
VICTIM.
ON YOU?
>> NO.
THEY TRIED TO -- I KIND OF GOT
MAD AND I STARTED PUNCHING WALLS
AND STUFF.
AND THEN A KID [BEEP] CAME AT ME
AND THREW ME ON THE GROUND.
>> AND SOME OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS TO THE CHAOTIC SCENE
LAST WEEK CAME FROM CORAL
SPRINGS P.D.
SPEAKING FOR THE FIRST TIME,
OFFICER JEFF HEINRICH WHO WAS
OFFDUTY AT THE TIME RUSHED IN AS
A COP, AS A FATHER OF A STUDENT,
AND HUSBAND OF THE SCHOOL'S
ASSISTANT ATHLETIC DIRECTOR.
>> BY THE GRACE OF GOD, WHEN I
WALKED DOWN THE HIGHWAY, THEY
FOUND EACH OTHER.
THEY WERE ABLE TO SHELTER IN
PLACE.
>> AND FLORIDA REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT TODAY
UNVEILING A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN.
THREE POINT ACTION PLAN DEALING
WITH MODIFYING GUN LAWS,
IMPROVING HOW WE DEAL WITH
MENTAL INSTABILITY AND ALSO
ADDRESSING SCHOOL SAFETY, FOR
EXAMPLE, MAKING SURE THERE IS AT
LEAST ONE ARMED OFFICER FOR
EVERY 1,000 STUDENTS AT EVERY
SCHOOL IN THE STATE.
AS FOR THE STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS, THEY RETURN
HERE ON WEDNESDAY OFFICIALLY
GETTING BACK TO SCHOOL AND
GETTING BACK TO THEIR CLASSROOMS
TO FINISH OFF THIS NOW FOREVER